[Music]
Robert Pattinson getting candid on
Tuesdays Howard Stern Show about his
past with Kristen Stewart's and his
future with longtime girlfriends sta
twigs and you feel Nazis that your own
gauge right 31 year old still playing
coy on engagement speculation he says
it's to protect the relationship from
quote Twilight crazy but he did at this
man she's amazing she's like super
talented and kind of it's kind of a
dream it's a totally different yet
totally different well he's victoriously
private now but wasn't a highly
publicized romance with this one where
Twilight co-star here's what Rob said
about max do you think because you throw
yourself into a role it was almost
inevitable that you would fall in love
with your co-star which probably I would
you advise that that's a good thing or a
bad thing for an actor starting out is
it better than just keep it like
separate or is it almost impossible not
to fall in love I don't know if it's
impossible but it definitely makes you
more of a paparazzi target yeah peg have
a relationship 100% it doesn't it make
the movie better too in the sense that
you're really actually falling in love I
don't know I mean sometimes it can like
you know Sony movies where you you can
make the people hate each other and for
some reason that how cuz whatever
alchemy kind of yeah it's a strange term
alchemy can in anything you know they
definitely noticed that on the first on
the first one it felt very different to
anything I've done before and anything
I'm done sense but it's kind of you have
that one moment II see something in you
and you kind of have this like that also
the heat for a second but I think I sort
of realized quite quickly like it sort
of wasn't necessarily real and I don't
be you know you can upset people really
quickly as well so you suddenly have
this power and you don't know you don't
really know what it is and so that you
can't really act the same